there was like kind of a meet and greet
event impromptu yesterday at hard house
but no more of those
one
oh that was something I had like put
together the last minute yeah
and I saw it but I was so tired already
and I texted him oh thanks so much Jeff
thank you they both ignored me sorry
I was like okay I'm sure they're still
there because I can see them on streams
over there and then I turned the stream
on and there was like a hundred yeah
there were so many people and the first
thing
I want to get covered
it ain't no way bro like and they all
like
there was a really cool photo that came
out of it though with like everybody I'm
very glad I could see that going from
one person to another yeah exactly no I
honestly I was like I have to go to like
the flat to that to a place we won't
name because we're on stream and I was
like oh okay great like I don't want to
get sick all right okay okay we have a
new game here
slowly
we're having a chest night here tonight
foreign
[Applause]
checked me and he was like oh you are
not cheating wow
people always younger in fact the guy
that interviewed and did the Peace in
the globe and mail today yeah for any
local thermometers or open mail I guess
you can read news anywhere right I read
it online
um but he asked me about the experience
of catching cheaters we will be talking
about current cheating controversies
because I don't know what you're talking
about we don't talk about those right
now we don't talk about Bruno but
um he asked me if we've ever not hired
someone because they're cheating and and
he told me that you already told him
that story yeah yeah and I said yeah
anytime we're going to hire someone we
see we go check their account and we
have not hired people because we checked
our account and saw that they cheated
and even if they were a great candidate
and we we have one experience a very
funny experience that I will not know
yeah it was long ago but we hired him
and he cheated in a staff tournament and
we but you did a staff tournament
against Great why would you ever cheated
against you against you why are people
like this you're gonna have to respect
the hustle on that one
but that's so ridiculous like one of
those things where
this guy was you know going to be one of
our very important developers and
someone who has like access to your most
critical code base
you can't have them doing that right
that's so I can't imagine people like
cheat while they're working
he really was like he almost shoot
against the head show he ain't gonna
know it's so funny if you think about it
you say it that way oh man this dude
this dude's name is like uh you know all
over the web so I'm I'm gonna beat him
though
a very interesting move but yeah you
made your position very interesting
I get funny ideas
you want to see
is Bobby okay I haven't heard back yet
okay
why are our games so interesting I just
just do it again yeah
yeah there's two interesting dudes
playing some games you know that's two
interesting dudes playing some
interesting chess oh damn I really like
I have a nice game against study and I
thought maybe I'm just you know like
it's my Resurgence and now I look over
and for the second time in a row I think
he's just taking it easy on us today
I'm lost
it's pretty too much time
and you know like what's funny I've
accepted my status on Earth as an I am
right right I play Bad Games or whatever
or I'm like I'm off
but I wonder
when you're 26.50 right like
you're probably still a killer
I wonder even in recreational games
you're just
like
oh yeah spicy over there
oh I'm here
here
sorry
you have the nicest shoes
yeah I'm just gonna like do this I I
don't even want to talk about what I'm
doing but I want to do it okay
I just want to see what we're doing here
I know I don't even care oh boy
you have lost all the Packers I've lost
all my goodness
I shouldn't have done it but I did it
not wrong Jake Paul's
I always have this one
no chat you cannot pass your moving
chest if you don't want it
that's this is not better nothing that I
did matter
what is this
um
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
up
oh my God
jeez Louise
I'm just not used
and here we see Dania knock you over
another piece and sacrifice
sorry that was funny okay
laughs
so fast it's all coming too fast
friendship yes
GG
that written
into sliding squares that's why why it
happens